howdy howdy
all right first few minutes I'm gonna be
testing and making sure everything's
working can you hear me can you guys
hear me
mike check
mic check is it picking up the right mic
I can't tell
um
I checked can you guys hear me hello
hello
please tell me the mic's working
the mic's not working I got problems
all right I don't know if you guys can
hear me or not
I don't seem to have an option so don't
wait I'm getting something hello hello
check mic check mic check
mic check
all right I don't know
we can hear you all right good to know
good to know I can't tell on my end from
how this is because I'm just doing it
over the web
all right so first I just want to say
hey thanks thanks to all you guys that
uh support me and subscribe and watch my
videos and all that it's huge
um sorry it took so long to do this
video I just kind of kept forgetting to
do it
and today I thought about it I was like
I'm just gonna do it I'm just gonna
gonna do it today so here we are
you guys are welcome to ask me whatever
you want and I'll try my best to answer
and that's uh that's pretty much all
this really is so
it's gonna be watching chat hanging out
and uh talking
I'm listening to you guys
and that kind of stuff
and whenever this is empty I'm going to
turn off the Stream So that that's
basically the plan
so with that um yeah I'm turning it over
to you guys going to be watching
launching the text
fly in or not fly in
so uh
trying to think here what I can say in
the meantime
until questions come in
of any sort I don't even know
trying to think what you guys might even
ask I don't even know actually
because I think most people they have
questions on videos they ask them in
comments on videos
so but yeah anything it's open even if
it's not about the channel
you can ask about whatever it's fine
doing my due diligence
this is the first time I've ever
streamed on YouTube
it's kind of interesting
planning on doing embedded stuff asked
by a broken heater
I don't have any current plans of doing
embedded stuff but I would like to the
only reason really is because I don't
work on anything embedded currently
usually I sort of do videos based off of
what I'm currently learning or working
on or what I already know
and I guess I know a little bit about
embedded but
I don't really have anything to practice
on
and make sure I'm actually saying things
correctly
but
if I ever get some device that requires
being programmed
I probably will
probably talk about it at least a little
I did some in school
did some Labs with embedded stuff and it
was pretty neat
it's fun enough
but yeah I'd like to I just don't really
have a good thing to practice on right
now
did I go to university yes I did I went
to uh two universities it's kind of a
bit of a story if I say the whole thing
but
I'll just uh make it brief
so right out of high school I went to
DeVry University
for a couple semesters and I went for
electronic engineering at first and then
I switched to computer science
and I didn't like it at all I did not
really enjoy my time at DeVry University
so
I quit after a few semesters
just wasn't feeling it but after that I
just basically worked mostly in it for
the next
10 years
then I went to Ohio University
for computer science and this time was
by choice when I went to DeVry it was
not by choice I was kind of just forced
to go and I just wasn't into it
although it was it was all right I guess
in some ways like I got introduced to
what programming was because I didn't
really experience that when I was a kid
but uh when I went later to Ohio
University I was all about it like my
main goal was basically to become a
programmer so I could build stuff that I
wanted to build so I was very into all
the programming classes focused hard on
them
did pretty good on them
did terrible in a lot of the other
classes because I just didn't care like
my English class I was like I don't care
I'll show to I'll show up but that's not
what I'm here for so I'm only doing it
because it's required and same with a
lot of other classes I was just I was
that kid that showed up
and just did the homework and stuff as
quickly as possible
in the other classes but only computer
science classes I studied hard and
worked hard on those
so and yeah graduated in uh 2018.
it was it was fun
I enjoyed it I'm glad I went
I learned a ton of stuff I didn't know
it was like
a lot of eye-opening experiences as far
as computer tech like I thought I was
good with computers and still until I
started
studying computer science and then I
realized like how much I didn't know so
it was pretty cool
it's just to have that I didn't really
have anyone around me in my life growing
up that
was interested in computers like my dad
was a farmer my mom was like a
stay-at-home mom so I just didn't get
any experience unless I went out and got
it myself
because my dad was actually an
agriculture agricultural engineer to be
more technical he went to school for
that
but yeah good times
met a lot of cool people in the
University that was uh something I
didn't really anticipate
to a program and C plus plus exclusively
I appreciate these questions by the way
broken heater you're uh keeping the
stream alive
um
our Lively rather this cup is keeping it
alive
programming C plus plus exclusively
the short answer is yes and the long
answer is no because uh I strongly
strongly prefer C plus plus so if I'm
ever given a choice of like you can code
in whatever language you want I always
choose C plus plus
but it's not entirely exclusive I've
programmed in other languages I built
Pro I built software and other languages
so
I just don't get as into them I usually
just figure out enough to get whatever
I'm working on done but with C plus plus
I study it in the ins and outs and
everything so I know it a lot better
that's why I basically talk about it if
I were if I were to talk about some
other language
I wouldn't know I would be lost a lot
and I would be like I gotta look up
stuff all the time make sure I'm saying
it correctly with C plus plus I can just
kind of wing it a little better since
I've studied it so much
C plus plus with double Hearts yeah I
love it I just love that it's so
versatile and that you can do anything I
guess that's somewhat true for other
languages but with C plus plus you can
like make it really efficient like no
matter what you're doing you can get
like maximum efficiency and I really
really like that and since I was
basically studying programming to make
games and you have to make them
highly optimized these days
it just made sense to go deep
yeah zero overhead principle
yeah I think that's uh one of the main
things that was created with according
to
Bjorn's true strip rust is better I have
no idea
I've heard rust is all right I don't
know if it's better
I don't know
um
I guess I would default to the answer of
no like it might be better at some
things like uh it might be better or it
might be easier to memory manage and
rust or something but it's not
particularly hard to begin with if you
just kind of
know what to look for and stuff it's
only hard when you're new to it
and once you like understand what you
have to do to manage memory it's not
really it's not particularly hard it's
it's as simple as like
think about like taking something out of
the fridge you take you take the milk
out of the fridge
you eventually got to put it back in you
know that's that's basically that it's
like
once you get kind of used to that it's
it's more complicated and that's highly
simplified
I don't really program in Rust I know
it's like the The Fad right now
I just I don't really have a reason to I
don't have anything against rust it's
just
if I ask myself why would I use rust to
do this instead of C plus plus
and I don't really have a reason so I
don't
seems good though I don't it reminds me
of uh like in school we programmed with
Oak camel
I don't know if you've ever heard of oh
camel I'll type in chat in case you
don't know
it's a lot like Oak camel
that's what it made me like just looking
at the syntax I'm like oh this is
basically old camel
it's uh it's a very type specific
language everything has to be properly
typed or else
and that's like their main thing I guess
it's
I don't know what else Russ does I'm
really not qualified to talk about rust
honestly I don't use it
I just I just see people's headlines
about it I use Russ to do
this or that and I'm like okay I don't
know
opinion on python I like python
um
I don't really have any problems with
python Python's cool because you can do
stuff super quick without worrying about
a lot of syntax really
a way one of my friends put it when he
was loving python is with python you can
literally open up your text editor and
just make lines of comments of what you
want your program to do and then you
just change those comments into the
actual python code and it just it just
works
um I don't use Python a whole lot
because I would just use cboss Plus
instead in general
but
seems all right
it seemed if you're really good with
python and you're really good with C
plus plus and you just want to get
something working with like within an
hour you need to get it as far along as
possible python would probably be a
little better
because with C plus plus you inevitably
end up messing with like a lot of
libraries and making sure a lot of stuff
is lined up correctly which takes a
little more time but it
C plus plus is way faster than python
from a runtime standpoint
all right
um
thanks for the thing I wish I could get
the comments on screen
I don't know I don't really have a way
to do that with the way this is
karna Aaron says I took a graphics
course last semester and your videos
helped me set up opengl Dev environment
thanks you're welcome
have you done 3D object rendering yeah
I've done that quite a bit
that's generally what I work on most
days is
3D objects stuff
uh I'm I'm a novice with 3D like when it
comes to designing stuff
but yeah I'm making a 3D game right now
so I'm always kind of messing with it
and learning more about it
New Year's plans
don't have anything major I'm kind of
starting to make plans for the next year
and general stuff I want to do
but uh
I don't really have specific plans
I guess I really want to get a
networking tutorial going and I really
want to get like a uh
I guess threading threading and
networking those are the the big things
that I want to get on the channel next
year
all right going down the line here I'll
get all your questions don't worry
I look at other programming languages
and I just can
says Nook like
I keep coming back to C plus plus
exactly that's exactly what happens to
me I try to do another language in a
second I'm going back to C plus plus so
they say it's hard but it feels easier
to me
Harry says the place I work at is trying
to migrate code from C plus plus to rust
basically to help
less worry about memory but still fast
cool be curious to hear how that goes in
the long run
World shaper says hey thanks for doing
this you're welcome
says do you prefer working Windows Linux
or Mac
that's actually a really tough question
for me to answer I uh I always end up
working on Windows just because it saves
me a lot of time basically I really
really like working on Linux and Mac 2.
I really enjoy it it's just I always run
into these scenarios where I get stuck
and I like can't fix it but on Windows
it's just ready to go so I'm like okay I
guess I'm going back to Windows so I can
move on
that always happens but I really love
Linux Mac for console stuff I'd highly
prefer Lennox and Mac definitely but
anything with a graphical interface I'd
rather do windows that's kind of how it
works for me
um
Joshua and patil says what's the best
way to learn boost libraries how about
doing a video on those that's a good
question
um
I'd say the best way is to just start
using them
um the Boost libraries are interesting I
haven't used them a ton I used to use
them but like the most used features in
the Boost Library usually get put in the
standard
so I used to use boost for like file
system and then I just put it in the
standard so I didn't have to use them
anymore
but yeah I would just say practice using
them like uh
I'd have to even look what all they have
anymore but
keep it simple
use one at a time
um just use what you need and
yeah I can maybe do specific videos on
certain ones
but uh yeah I'd have to have some idea
to go off of I guess
all right
okay on let's see on the topic of the C
plus plus the rest from karna Aaron um
translating The Matrix math code is
really tough
like creating the bezier curves
interesting
yeah I believe it
World shaper ass is it still worth
programming
neurons and C plus plus in your view is
it still worth programming
I mean it really depends on the person I
think if you want to program it's
and I don't know how to answer that
really
just yeah
I love programming so it's always worth
it for me
but if it's like
I know some people like program out of
necessity and they really don't like it
so I would say in that case maybe it's
not worth it if you really don't enjoy
it but that's really
up to each person I think
yeah that's kind of a hard one to dig
into
tips on what kind of projects can build
to get a job as a graphics programmer CS
with decent C plus plus also thanks for
your work okay that's from kairal
correct no sorry if I mispronounced
names
uh cool uh you're welcome um having to
be helpful let's see kind of projects
I think really
this is a tough question
but I think I think I know how to
simplify the answer
basically you want to get really good at
the main features
that Graphics libraries offer like start
with opengl
uh kind of learn all the basic Graphics
techniques understand how the vertices
and indices normals work
and uh and lighting it's kind of a big
thing
but basically you you'd probably want to
get really good with understanding all
the possibilities of what you can do
with graphics and shaders so shaders are
going to be big there too learn opengl
is a really nice starting point going
through that will get you a huge Head
Start and with all the basics and a lot
of the industry stuff and it's opengl
but it doesn't matter because like the
math and the techniques transfer to any
renderer so definitely a nice free
research resource there that
yeah they'd help me a ton at my points
like okay but on the topic of getting a
job as a graphics programmer sure you
can learn all this stuff but no one's
going to hire you unless they really
like your resume so resumes can be
tricky to do right for programming
basically you want to take like one of
your best projects and make like a
highlight reel of cool features you want
them you want someone to be able to look
at a 30 second video of your stuff and
be like okay this guy could do some cool
stuff because if you convoluted with a
bunch of little projects
companies will be like I I can't tell
what you're good at basically so I would
say do something like that
uh can you make a 3D opengl Graphics
course
I would like to maybe I can work on some
I didn't I don't know if any many people
have seen it didn't get super popular
but I did uh opengl course for a while I
think I got 11 episodes in or so
um
there should be a lot of 3D ones the
Cherno has a has one an opengl playlist
I don't know
I had a hard time watching all the
episodes but I tried to I try to keep up
with his
um I feel like most of them are too long
and dry and I felt even that way about
mine maybe
but uh yeah I could analyze that and see
what I could do I can't make any big
promises though
like I don't know it's just like there's
just so much like where do you where do
you where do you leave off when you
start making those it's like a year long
oh also ogl Dev ogl Dev does a bunch of
really great opengl tutorials too so
they're out there they do out there
they do exist on YouTube
uh
Joshua Patel says shared porno or
tutorial seems easy to understand but
not sure which real use case it would be
useful any clues
um shared pointer is
basically if you're passing the pointer
all over the place and you don't want to
have to worry about
okay let me try to simplify this down
because if I just say what I'm thinking
it's going to be it's not going to make
sense
like
okay so the point of a shared pointer is
it keeps track of how many people are
using it
So you you're first instantiated
somewhere and then if like you have some
other class or object that wants that
same pointer
you give it to it as well and you don't
really have to worry about when it gets
deleted because it keeps references and
whenever the reference count is zero
that's when it deletes so if you're
having to track a bunch of different
places where a pointer is going shared
pointer might be a good case for it if
like a bunch of things are using it at
once basically so it's it's pretty handy
whereas with a unique pointer only one
thing can use it at once
so
that's the big difference
I don't use them a ton anymore actually
I just manually keep track of it I don't
know for me in my head it works better
if I just use raw pointers
but I I don't know
I don't think that's necessarily the
best thing to do is just
what I do sometimes
best is learn opengl book yeah that's
good that's definitely good really
enjoyed your pointer to implementation
video oh the pimple pretty useful cool
thank you yeah I love that the pimple I
use it quite frequently
uh let's see what else we got
videos offer a lot of value sure takes a
lot of time and work thanks for the
tutorials especially cmake you're
welcome
and welcome lewisville's uh Nathan asks
what are your favorite programming books
good question good question
um
I have two that I tend to read when I'm
bored or when I'm going somewhere and
know that I'm going to be sitting there
talking to no one let me just show you
I'll get them real quick hold on
foreign
foreign
this one
this one put me Miles Ahead at one point
yarn Street strips uh programming
principles and
practice using C plus plus
he explains like everything you can do
with C plus plus in this book it is
awesome
I'll leave affiliate links to these down
below later
if I remember
this one was from an AI class man it's
reversed isn't it
it's just AI by
Charles Luger it's not necessarily the
best AI book out there but this will
teach you a lot about this graph Theory
and uh basically
that kind of stuff it's looking pretty
good and this one this one's free online
it's the uh Robert nice drums game
programming patterns
these are the three I own that I
peruse through all the time but there
are a lot of good ones
all right let's see
all right I tried to make that as quick
as possible and so I could
it's tough time to do other ones
okay where did I leave off
yeah those are those are my favorite
right now
I really want to get the uh the
programming black book
from uh I think it's about doom and all
the stuff used to program Doom
originally
that's one I really want to get but I
just haven't gotten yet
so I don't have an opinion on it yet but
I've heard it's really really cool
all right the sure no touch is on 3D but
doesn't go into normals lighting shading
too deep okay I see
all right thanks karna best of luck
to you as well and everyone
uh someone recommends computer Graphics
programming and opengl with C plus plus
by Clevenger and Gordon
okay
I haven't heard that one yet but
it's fairly recent it might be
updated with a lot of new stuff
oh so these aren't you can like read
this lettering properly it's not
reversed for you guys
on my
sample screen it's reversed it's
mirrored
but if it isn't for you guys then cool
there are two semi-different muscles for
building a
building a big problems and so your
thoughts which is more valuable in the
21st hold on let me make sure I can read
this question right
if there are two semi different muscles
for building
for a building a big problem and so
I don't understand I'm sorry I don't
understand the question
hey do you ever end up
comparing your progress to others and
how do you stop that from discouraging
you
uh that's an excellent question that's a
really good question
and I'm trying to think how to answer it
well because my I know my answer is not
going to work for other people
no problem World chamber yeah I think I
have get the question but I don't I
don't really know how to quite answer
but yeah if you can
okay so Ankita to answer your question
about
comparing your progress to others and
how to keep that from discouraging you
like I I have a technique but I don't
I'm kind of afraid to share my technique
because I don't want other
people don't necessarily do this I don't
I don't know if it's a particularly
healthy or well
uh
well whatever well adjusted way of doing
it but basically
I go into like a mode of thought
where I stopped caring
and see that that's why it's like you
that's something you don't want to say
right you don't want to say stop caring
but that's basically what I do I look at
other people's awesome stuff I'll learn
from it and I'll say that's cool and
then the feeling creeps up that like
I'm never going to get there you know
that kind of feeling
and that feels discouraging and I just
say too bad two bad feelings I don't
care about you
you're not you're not right so it's just
kind of like a it's a very a beat myself
up approach but it's like beat my beat
this myself up that's already beating
myself up so it's like this internal
fight of
you know I don't know it doesn't make
it's it's hard to explain
but it's something like that I basically
just stopped caring
and uh and I use like another part of me
to fight the other part of me and it
just turns into this like mush of all
right what can I work on who cares about
what they're doing what can I work on
and uh eventually I'll get you know you
kind of get there
so that's my that's my weird technique
of uh not comparing myself to others I
love watching what other people do and
it I do have that feeling of man there's
so much further ahead and and usually
it's like math stuff it's like they're
doing all this cool stuff like flying
around the world with planes and I'm
like I have no clue how to do that but
I'll watch your video and think it's
cool and I don't know
all right I'll move on
but I think the important thing to do is
just make the steps that you can make
it's really good when you see that kind
of stuff to like take notes of what
they're doing that you can't do
and come back to that and like look at
that and be like okay what are the steps
to get good at this thing that I felt
like I couldn't do and you can start
taking those little steps to get there
so that's I think that's about all we
can do really
all right
building a big Pro okay I'll wait a
little
bit
yeah see if that if that works then
awesome but yeah I'm kind of I was kind
of scared to share that because I think
it's such a
I don't know if other people would even
accept that or think it's weird but
that's kind of just how it works for me
also
I might trying to think about how to say
this part
I think I have a I don't know how to
word this I definitely have some kind of
God I don't know how to say this
like when it comes to C plus plus and
programming I just know what I want to
do
and like
it's more of the end goal I don't like I
don't really even care about the little
steps in between it's like I'll get I'll
do anything to get there kind of thing
and it it's sort of like an insane
Psychopathic strategy to to see like I
want to make a huge awesome game
and there's all this stuff blocking it
like oh you got to get good at this and
this and this and I'm like I don't care
I don't care what it takes I'm doing it
it's like it's like just a crazy
I told that too I said that in an
interview once too and I got the job
they're like what makes you like C plus
plus and I I think I looked at him I
said insanity
I completely got that job
but uh
all right
okay so okay the question from earlier
that I wasn't sure World shaper says
what's more important building a big
project
or solving small
but considered hard problems in
inventing math and leak of problems
I definitely feel like you need both
definitely feel like you need both
building a big project I guess like
what's what's a big project for you
like a multi-faceted does a bunch of
things type project
or like a like a big I don't know I
guess depends on your definition of big
project
I think building a big project is super
important because you learn how to
intertwine a bunch of pieces together
like you learn how to
store stuff long term in your program
and then bring it up later or save it
and bring it up later and you learn how
to do all these little things that
require like specific design
and it basically like forces you to
think in a way
that uh
that scales well and it's it's really
hard at first and it might take you a
few tries but if you like keep coming
back to it you're sort of realizing new
stuff at least that's how it was for me
I haven't built anything super huge
cool but uh like all the projects I got
in school they were all relatively small
you could do them single file or
something you know
they kind of just did one thing but the
first big project I did on my own was DM
power and it had to do like a ton of
stuff and it took me like four or five
tries before I got the structure right I
just kept having to delete everything
and start over
but once I got it all right and it was
all working
I was like
I did it basically over a summer why we
didn't have school and I came back to
school in the next semester and I was
like miles ahead of my peers like
I I basically felt like they were all
noobs and I had to teach them everything
and it was just from doing that one
project on the side that was that did a
bunch of stuff that I had to fail at a
bunch of time to start over and figure
out the structure
like it just put me so far ahead of
everyone else and that that was really
interesting though because I was like
I didn't necessarily feel like I was the
best coder in my classes but after that
like after that one summer of building
that big project big for me at the time
I was so much better but in solving the
small problems
uh I would say those are important too
they come up usually and when you're
building stuff
I don't know I don't really I don't
really know how to
I usually like solve the problems that
come up I rarely go look for problems
um I usually just like
if a problem comes up
I've learned how to solve it but if it
never comes up I don't go like search it
out
so I feel like
maybe doing the smaller hard problems
are kind of like
you know like specific reps like you go
to a gym and do curls or something you
know you're working on a specific muscle
so they're probably more like that
I guess
I don't know
it's definitely good to know them like
all those main algorithms in the leak
code if you know those you'll
it makes a huge difference
because uh stuff will come up where you
need to know how to do it quickly and
you'll be like oh this is like the same
pattern from what I understand with
those leak code patterns there's like
10 or so main patterns and they just
keep reappearing over and over so once
you kind of know all of those
you should be pretty good so you don't
necessarily have to do the small hard
problems forever they're probably good
just to like get an initial feel for him
so I think building a big project is
more important in my view going forward
because that's that's how you make real
software You Gotta Have You Gotta solve
big you gotta tie a bunch of things
together
and that's more important than if your
for Loop is fast enough because you can
always fix your for Loop later but if
you've got things structured in a way
that doesn't make sense that's really
hard to fix later
that's just an exaggeration but
all right next some nerd asked
dop versus oop are you strong on either
I guess I'm strong on oop but I don't I
have no idea what oh dop is
Dynamic something programming I don't
even I don't even know what dop is
I don't think I've ever heard of that
you have to let me know data oriented
programming
okay
oh yeah yeah
I use a lot of I used a ton of dop in my
Archer engine
like everything in there is dop pretty
much from what I understand
but I've never specifically studied it I
was just doing things in a way and then
I noticed later that that's a data
oriented way it's basically everything
operates on
how much data you have in the engine
so
I don't know I guess I'm okay at both
probably better at ohope but I
I don't really think about it too much
really I guess
Health question how do you deal with
stress and frustration frustration
tolerance has dropped for me after years
of school
uh good question
I don't know if I have a good answer for
that
how do I deal with stress
I usually try to address it
I think is the big thing
um if someone or something is really
stressing me out
I usually cut it off
I think is the big thing which might not
be healthy and you can't do that with
everything I understand so
I think the best thing you can do is
try to understand the problem that's
called causing the stress it could be
anything could be like I don't know I'll
just bring up a random example like when
I was in school I had a young kid and
sometimes when I was trying to study or
get work done he like really wanted to
play
and that's that was like fine
but I just basically had to
um it was like stressful to me because I
was like I got this thing due gotta turn
it in by seven o'clock I don't have time
to play kid I'm sorry and he would be
like come on you know and it was it was
hard it was stressful
but basically I had to like find I had
to like analyze and find Solutions so
sometimes I just like
call up someone that had kids and I was
like hey uh can you come like can you
just bring your kids and like come hang
out with my kid for a while it was stuff
like that I was just like
just try to find a way or I would take
him to another family and be like all
right I gotta go I got stuff to do
it's due soon so I I think just
analyzing the problem like realizing
that it's stressful
and like telling somebody that cares but
in like the nicest way you can and help
them
kind of get them to understand your play
because it was always like hey I got
this thing due I uh my kid really needs
attention but I can't really give it to
him or I'm gonna fail this thing
and I'm putting between a rock and a
hard place
you know if I had to choose I'm going to
choose family but I'm paying a lot of
money to go to school so like ah what do
I do you know so a lot of times it was
like
I would call someone and be like hey you
know just let them know and if you can
do it heads up you do a last minute it
doesn't really work but if you can see
that like oh I gotta spend a lot of time
on this let's plan ahead planning ahead
makes a big deal for
dealing with stress just knowing that
the stressful situation is coming up so
you can kind of prepare
that helps but I don't know that's a
hard question to answer
and uh given specific examples I might
be able to answer a little better
but I don't really feel a whole lot of
stress with other with with things
anymore I guess I mean I do at times but
it's different
I don't know I'd have to give a very
specific things I don't know if I want
to get too specific
but generally it's something like that
it's just like realizing that there's a
stressful situation ahead and kind of
planning the best I can to
mitigate it
like if you know you got a hard math
test
you study the most you can the day
before that kind of thing and it makes
it less stressful
you know stuff like that that's uh best
I can do I think now
how should one brush up their oop
definitely practice
just just work with
you know that's not that's probably not
a good answer off the top right just
practice and everyone knows that but
find something to work on that's oop
and uh maybe build something from
scratch where you've got a bunch of
different objects and they all talk
together in one main program or
something you know or one borrows from
the other and try to like understand
those concepts of how I'm borrowing this
object and things like that
it's like the more you do it the more
you understand
kind of what to do with the memory and
the data
in the objects if you will
from what I see dob is about keeping
data and code separate
while oop is more about polymorphism and
having to code and data together okay
yeah
yeah I can make sense of that
yeah I think I I think my brain is
oriented towards dop because I like
having big sections of data and then
feeding that to code
the whole polymorphism thing did not
come naturally to me
I really had to study that to figure it
out I mean like the the basic concept of
it is simple but
like in my design patterns it's it's all
polymorphism pretty much
like none of that none of that just came
automatically to me I had to like really
study it to put that all together
thank you for your thoughtful answer
World shaper says oh you're welcome
cool do you work on Consulting projects
on the side occasionally they come and
go
yeah mostly it's just a lot of uh a lot
of side teaching and stuff
so a lot of various sessions with often
people new to coding and stuff just uh
helping them along doing a session here
and there
few projects
not many projects recently but I've done
quite a few in the past
those are the side projects from other
people
they're often very convoluted and just
too much work
like a lot of times someone would be
like oh can you help me with this and I
want to but then when I get into it I'm
like this is going to take me months and
they're only offering like 100 bucks and
it's like I can't I just can't that's
I can spend a couple hours on it but I'm
not going to get much done in a couple
hours other than starting to understand
what the project
actually how it works you know so
consulting's weird I don't think I have
a good front-end setup of how to
uh
I guess plug for consulting stuff I want
to try to work on that in the new year
I know YouTube is more of a side project
you what do you do as your main job good
question
um
I've had well
there's no good way for me to answer
this
um I basically just work on my game
engine as my main job and it doesn't
really pay anything right now so
um I'm not exactly making a ton of money
or anything
I make enough to survive based on side
projects YouTube
and a couple other small things so it's
like
probably have about eight or so small
um Revenue incomes
some of them a little bigger than others
so with all those combined I typically
make enough to pay my bills and save a
little
and I worked at a university for about
10 years
and I worked at a couple other pretty
big places for a couple years well not
not quite a couple years
but I was able to save up from a lot of
those so
not exactly struggling but I'm not I'm
also not making a ton so I'm kind of
fine to work on my my game for about
another year I think and hopefully I
plan on releasing it at the end of 2023
so hopefully that generates yet another
stream of income and helps me keep going
but that yeah that's basically what I do
for the most part I was looking for a
few jobs here and there but there's not
much locally in my area I live in kind
of a rural place which I like because
it's
it's very peaceful and nice
but there's not a whole lot of
opportunities around my area for coders
anyway so I was considering starting up
some kind of game studio so I might do
something like that
so it's on the the back burner
um I hope that answers it well enough
what is your tolerance of distraction
and maintaining Focus how do you respect
your focus how much do you think others
respect your focus oh God
focus is hard for me
um
it's definitely very easy for me to like
open up YouTube and start watching like
various things that aren't important
and uh like forget to code for like an
hour or two so usually what I have to do
if I really want to focus is I have to
sit down that day and make a plan early
on and be like okay today I'm going to
fix this part of my code or work on this
and I have to start Pomodoro app
and put on some classical music I tried
like heavy
uh music like synthwave and stuff and
that's all right for about 30 minutes
but after that it starts to become
fatiguing but like light classical music
helps me focus in starting the Pomodoro
app
uh pomodores for about 50 minutes with
coding
and then taking five to ten minute
breaks that seems to work pretty well
for me because I can really get into a
problem in 50 minutes
and uh
and then the 10 minute break I'll go get
a drink I'll work out a little bit of
stretch come back another 50 minutes
work on the problem
that seems to work pretty good for my
focus I really I have to turn off
YouTube I can't have a video on the side
a lot of people code with videos on the
side that makes it impossible for me to
get anything done I I can sit there for
eight hours with my editor right in
front of me and if there's like a
distracting video on the side
I will get nothing done so I really have
to cut that off
and there's no good way because my brain
like wants it it's like have some extra
stuff it's like that doesn't work I
can't I can't
I find I can't focus well enough on
multi-faceted problems it's like they
say your brain can only remember what
seven things you can only focus on seven
things at a time
so
I think when you're watching a video on
the side that counts as like three
because you get you get audio you get
video and like both of those take
processing and then maybe something else
so you'll you're like almost half
your brain power and this is like that's
no good I can't go half brain power and
do this hard code stuff
so
it's just really kind of cutting that
off
s me
that's that's the big thing in the
Pomodoro stuff
oh that find myself giving in to
compulsions to check social media yeah I
have that problem too I'm always like
popping open Twitter Discord and
Facebook anything new and oh yeah that
that wrecks me too it's it's the same
concept with YouTube I just have to cut
it off
usually what I do is I close all my
browsers
except for like one tab maybe plain like
classical music
and I'll have another instance of a new
window and it's specifically for only
looking up documentation no social media
allowed
I usually close Discord or
I have all my servers muted on Discord
I'll go check them when I have time to
check them I don't want notifications or
beeps no notifications no beeps very
strict on that too if I'm working
there can't be any of that the only ones
I allow are my text messages and phone
calls
because they could be important but
everything else is no
if I have one I won't get anything done
that's
just coming to the reality of
uh if I have that stuff up or on I won't
get anything done and it's like I have
to make the choice do I want to get
stuff done or do I want to
check media and it's like I gotta choose
I can't do both
and that's what I've noticed anyway I
hope that helps
foreign
yeah flow State's important the Pomodoro
50-minute pomodoros and during that 50
minutes be really strict like if you
catch yourself starting to open social
media you'll just be like no cut it off
only documentation allowed
what am I working on you know for me
actually this is a crazy thing that
helps
um with the focus if I really want to
get something that done today I just
open up a blank notepad and I literally
write one thing at the top and I just
put you know the line of the one thing I
want to get done today like today it was
uh a capsule
uh physics collider from my player class
to move around as a capsule collider
that's that was the one thing I wanted
to get done today and that's the one
thing on my list and it's like that's
all I'm focusing on and I got it done
it's done it works
finally but I literally had to put that
as the one thing on my list for today to
get it done and I had to look up a ton
of stuff learn a ton of stuff
to actually get it right it took some
took some tricks
all right I'll keep going I'm a little
behind so I'm gonna try to go faster
Scott cross says a huge thank you as a
CS major you're welcome glad I could be
helpful acne says please upload the CMA
y'all upload it oh well I'll just put it
on the channel as a video it's fine
Cairo says
I completely left social media besides
professional stuff
not a bad Strat I guess now everyone's
different though
I I almost deleted Facebook yesterday
actually I was like do I just delete
this but I can't bring myself to quite
to do it so what I did instead is I made
everything all my all my details private
all my interests all my work history all
my where you moved like everything about
me just private online status disabled
so even if I am looking at it no one's
going to be like oh uh Matt's online let
me message them that doesn't happen
anymore because I'm just full private
but the only thing I left open is people
can send me friend requests that's the
one thing you can do well you can
message me if you're a friend or
whatever but for some reason that helped
like that felt good because the main
reason I wanted to delete it was just
privacy concerns and I was like well if
I just make everything unavailable and
it's just
feels kind of like Discord or something
when you when you do that you just turn
everything else off the whole profile
features
so that felt nice and that seemed to
help me
but uh yeah I don't know I don't know
about leaving social media entirely
I mean you can if you want to I don't
think there's anything wrong with
leaving it but
if you get use out of it or if you're a
public figure you kind of got to have
something
fascinating how intuitive oop seems to
be but it still takes years to do well
agreed
he worked for a uni for 10 years while
you look 26 I am turning I'm turning 39
in January so I'm a little older than I
look I guess
are a little younger than I look I said
that backwards
but yeah I worked at uh on an it desk at
a university for about 10 years total
the first couple years were contract I
used to repair laptops and optimize
laptop builds and stuff did that for a
while and then I switched to a desk
because it paid more and had insurance
and saved up a bunch there basically I
saved up enough to actually go to school
and it was
that's where I transitioned into
computer science
which was I decided I really wanted to
do after studying some more game Studio
sounds cool I love Pomodoro music is
great Celtic music yeah maybe I could
see Celtic Celtic or Celtic I don't know
all right I listened to Half-Life ones
guns and riffs extended version hmm I'll
check that out
arcbold asked do you ever ask for help
advice from fellow coders when you're
stuck on a task or just barrage on your
own is feedback important to you that's
a good question
um
I don't really have anyone to ask I know
it sounds weird but
I mean I can I can ask around
some in like my Discord or a few other
coder friends but
like everyone I went to school with
I don't I don't know any of them anymore
that are still doing like
serious coding most of them went on to
kind of menial
I would not necessarily mean most of
them went on to
some kind of industry job that doesn't
involve coding oddly enough so
I don't really have a whole lot of code
or friends that are at the same level as
me that I can actually ask usually if
I'm asking they'll say I don't know
that's all her problem so I usually just
Google it to death I just Googled Google
and Google and dig and try and practice
and scrap code and redo it and
eventually I'll figure it out that's I
do that all the time
that's what I did with this whole
physics thing it took me
three days because I was using physics
has a px controller
class thing and I thought oh a player a
player controller class in physics
perfect let's use that that's not the
thing you use for a player controller
and how would you ever figure that out
it's literally pull the player
controller but it's not the right thing
to use so I was digging and digging like
how do you make this player controller
be affected by gravity and all this
stuff and
no one had an answer and I was like what
how does no one have an answer for this
I don't get it and then I just found out
that you don't use that that's for like
flying cameras that clip through walls
and stuff that's the only time you use
that not for actual player characters
and I was just like
but yeah no one no one on the internet
seemed to know that so
all right uh is feedback important to
you somewhat
somewhat I'm I'm I don't know
I don't know how to
foreign
feedback is you got to be very careful
with feedback because
most I gotta be careful how I word this
I'll say half a half of the people that
give you feedback
don't even know what they're talking
about so you shouldn't be listening to
them
so you got to be very careful about who
you listen whose feedback you listen to
very careful
most people will just lead you astray
like I have this just random quick
example trying to make it quick
I play Magic the Gathering and I play a
lot of uh Legacy recently which is like
a old Eternal format
and it's very competitive most people
that play in it are like super good at
the game so it's rather challenging and
uh I have this friend I I've always
played magic with and I was like hey I'm
playing you know I just kind of
mentioned them playing a lot of Legacy
if anyone else wants to practice let me
know
and he just started chatting me up about
it giving me all this advice
but he doesn't even play the he doesn't
even play Legacy and he started like
recommending me cards that are banned
and I'm like you don't even know what
you're talking about you're trying to
get me to play band cards I would
literally get game losses and kicked out
of tournaments if I listen to you so
just to say you don't listen to everyone
they often don't know what they're
talking about
though it's It's Tricky
I don't know that that's something that
just happened recently and my mind was
blowing I'm like are you seriously
trying to get me to play band cards
come on just just go through research or
something uh
all right very good some nurses I think
your video prevents me from doing deep I
think videos prevent me from doing deep
problem solving like the multifacet
problems yeah the distraction from
videos is real
I can only do shallow work yep I feel
that like if you just gotta like drag
around the interface elements and make
them look pretty or you're drawing
something I think it's kind of okay
but when you're like trying to solve a
bunch of things it's just using up too
much of your bandwidth
building a big project and a subjective
view would be something I have been
dreaming about building
come up with a design and try to build
it
moving home theater project around four
sides of my room well it's Epic
project on opposite sides of my body
position that sounds very complicated
but cool
thanks some nerd he says going to sleep
now enjoy your rest
I pause arkbold says uh thanks for the
content I randomly found you while
learning cmakestate for great videos
welcome
guys are both thorough and entertaining
thank you
Arduino server oh for the moving
projector Arduino server Motors belt
that can create motion cool
first phase of the project
cool well
that sounds like an interesting project
I did with this the same with LinkedIn
all right now LinkedIn is a different
thing I honestly think all coders should
delete LinkedIn that's just my personal
opinion I don't really have anything
directly against LinkedIn it's just that
like
it's so spammy it's worse than and it's
like I don't know for me at least like
I would be
absolutely amazed if I ever got any sort
of actual job lead from LinkedIn it's
always just like
a bunch of recruiters spamming you with
stuff and if you say like okay I'm
interested to any of them
they like either don't answer or they
like
waste your time they'll say like okay
send me this and this and then they like
don't respond I don't know I just I've
never had a good experience with
LinkedIn I deleted it I deleted my
LinkedIn
a note out of that one
last comment from Sumner I try to log
out of social media and increase
friction of Checkmate but now I'm asleep
okay
yeah do what you got to do
Joshua said you're a hero your story is
great how you taught yourself keep the
good work and good luck with everything
looking forward to what you do well
thank you I appreciate that I
I'm glad I'm inspiring people I
I never intended to do this I never
planned on like I don't know
it's just it's just interesting that
people look up to me because I
I just wanted to make the games that I
kind of like tried to design when I was
a kid basically that was that was really
all my goal was and it was such a
frustrating experience getting started
basically because like I felt like the
material to get started wasn't out there
and that's why I started making the
YouTube videos I'm like I finally this
literally took me all day to figure out
something just some random concept and I
couldn't find anything on the internet
I'm just going to record a video about
it and just put it up and that was it I
was like I didn't really expect
anyone to latch on or or like get well I
kind of expected some people to be
helped by it because I was in the
situation where I was like I wished I
could have fine found this video I'm
making right now
and that was all it was really I was
just trying to kind of help some people
get started as well and
it's kind of cool that it's grown to
this and there's community and it's it's
awesome it's changed my life absolutely
and I just really appreciate you guys
and just want to keep
keep providing useful stuff more than
anything is just like
I have this deep desire to be useful I
guess in some way and I'm always
frustrated when there's like very easy
things to do but no one teaching it and
it's like this is so easy and useful but
nobody knows how to do it
why not let's make a quick video about
it let's teach people
all right
would you be able to do a video about
start to finish real world project for
example structure GitHub layout best
practices but yeah that would be a good
one I've considered doing something like
that it's a problem the only problem
with that is it's like it's too big of a
thing
um I think I have a video called C plus
plus crash course
that might be the best
hey best I can
kind of do really because if I start
doing a real project
it's just two in the weeds like there's
too many days of like
just figuring out things that aren't
exactly entertaining and it's really
hard to like
condense that into a video and then the
problem there is often making the video
takes more time than doing the actual
code so it's like for me it's like I
finally got this done I'm ready to move
on but if I have to make a video on the
subject it's like oh now I can't move on
I gotta make a video first so really
kind of
kind of messes up my real real world
project idea if I start making videos on
it that's why I'm not making videos on
my current game specifically because of
that because if I made a video on
everything I got done I would have a
really hard time getting further in the
game
it would just like basically double the
development time and I can't do that
but I do plan on making a few like
little things here and there about it
which I kind of have already but I plan
on making a few more of those but
nothing like super deep because it's
just it's just too much
uh sorry video we're live and jumped in
you apply for some job positions I've
applied for a few
not many
um
I guess no no actually I didn't apply I
that's kind of a lie I I answered a few
emails from recruiters
I didn't apply I just said this sounds
interesting to an email that's all I did
uh and you know talk to them a bit so I
don't know if that counts as applying or
not
uh I guess I applied to a few like a
couple years ago and
then stuff happened and I couldn't even
go forward anyway like I applied
I think the company John Deere applied
to them
and wrote a whole cover letter and
someone contacted me and they were
interested and I was on a place where I
couldn't do it anyway so I just didn't
respond and I felt bad and did not
respond after putting in all that effort
so I kind of just stopped after that I
was like uh by the time they got back to
me I was in a different place and
wouldn't do it anyway so
um
welcome Dave
don't you enjoy the videos on the Sergio
says I feel like a lot is Word of Mouth
opportunities yeah
saw your video of
visitor design pattern at the same time
gone into the design patterns but cool
it was weird and design patterns are
very useful for learning how to
structure things in a way that scales
well
I found them to be quite useful lately
wanted to thank you for your channel
seems there are not a lot of good
materials for C plus plus yeah it's
definitely it's definitely a very Niche
thing there's a like a very few specific
ones
found with found you with your cmake
stuff cool
um
I'm always wondering why my cmake videos
did so well
like I I did those on a whim one day and
they seem to be my most popular videos
they're definitely not the ones I've
worked hardest on or anything so that's
it's very interesting to me that they're
like the most popular I guess it's
because it applies to such a wide
variety of different types of C plus
plus programmers
something like that and I think I may
have simplified it in a way that a lot
of people resonated with which is cool
I'm glad they're very helpful I just
it always surprises me that they're my
most popular
because I I probably put the least
amount of work into that series and just
it was a very wing it series
uh get into game mode get into game
doses keep it up having fun pretty sure
hustle thanks maybe you should contact
with John Cena with Cherno
I'm not a big Reacher out honestly but
I've kind of thought about doing stuff
like that but I just don't even know
what I'd say
I I don't even know what I
I don't really have anything to say or
ask or I don't know
do you think that C plus plus 17 and 20
standards are more of a mean for a
person who's trying to build a portfolio
or should modern standards be used in
building slide projects yeah you might
as well use the modern stuff they're all
backwards compatible so
even if you're not necessarily using the
new features you can still in your build
system use whatever your compiler
supports and you know they're they're
more stable in general there's no reason
not to use them
suppose that's the way it goes yeah
for the cmake series so if yeah I guess
that's the way it goes I need to do a
couple more but
the ones I need to do next are kind of
require a lot of work so that's why I've
been putting them off like I want to do
one on the uh I did C test and I was
supposed to do the C dashboard next and
I've been putting that off for so long
because I know it's going to take me
like a full two days of work to do it
right
so I've been putting it off
Krill says I know 3D relearn
I know 3D relearns we're looking for a
porting programmer and a few other
positions
that's cool I'm pretty good at porting
stuff usually
but I don't know depends on
depends on what their
whole offer and stuff was
it always depends
I'm sorry I don't know how to say your
name I'm just going to call you NG NG
Cerna NG what about going back to school
I I keep wanting to go back to school
actually
um get a masters in something I just
can't decide on what and I'm not 100
convinced that it's I don't know yeah
I'd like to go back to school I've been
considering it for like two years
straight I just haven't
haven't uh
bid the bulletin done I guess what's
your opinion on yeah because it's still
a thing what I don't remember what Yak
is I've seen it heard of it can't
remember what it is
yet another compiler compiler
oh I don't know
I'd have to uh have to do research to
know not sure
oh is that where you like there's a
pre-compiler in front of your compiler
type of thing
I guess
you know it's like typescript is in
front of JavaScript or yeah in front of
JavaScript that type of stuff
3D Realms okay
not 3D relearns
um
they can be useful I don't personally
ever use the compilers in front of
compilers but
I can see how they can be handy or
useful especially with keeping syntax
clean
if you only want to do specific features
or something
but I don't know it's just not something
I really
do usually if I want a compiler in front
of my compiler I just make a function
and pass it some simple stuff
and it does all the hard work so that's
usually how I approach that
like if I've got a really hard thing
that takes a giant amount of code and
I'm basically condensing it down into
some smaller thing it's like I'll just
make a function I'll pass in whatever it
is and it'll do all the work
and that's my pre compiler essentially I
know it's not the same thing but that's
kind of just it seems better to me than
writing a whole new compiler to just
write a function that handles it
your specific case that's bugging you
what are the different types of C plus
plus programmers I guess there's like
embedded ones there's there's game
specific ones this is not a technical
answer I'm just kind of guessing
there's definitely game programmers they
only want to know how to like code up
graphics and vectors and math stuff
there's definitely embedded ones who are
more worried about
uh memory management type stuff and
super fast
things running on small devices with
limited memory
and I'm sure there's more I'm just not
thinking of them
good morning how did you get start
getting into programming saysna
um I got started
there was two different incidences where
I got started the first one was I
started at DeVry and I got forced into
it with some Java and stuff
I wasn't interested at that time but I
kind of got forced into it so I learned
a tiny bit there
uh and then later it was just
I just really wanted to build games
basically and when I looked it up about
how to get good at it and how to learn
it was like
one of the options was computer science
it seemed to be a
you know it didn't it wasn't not
required but it's like you're going to
get a really good base of everything if
you take a computer science degree so I
just jumped on that also had a decent
offer to like get half my tuition paid
so I was like okay that's what we're
doing
and then uh I didn't even really know
that much about with C plus plus was
when I started but I had my first C plus
plus class and I got I got really lucky
I'll say because I had a teacher that
was awesome the teacher was so cool and
I was just like so into it I was just
like
this I couldn't believe how cool it was
which I was probably the only person in
the class thinking that but I was like I
was like front of the class studying
everything
no that was that person
um
but it just really enthralled me and me
and the teacher got along really well
and that that kind of really set me up
to to love C plus plus I think was that
first class
just goes to show you how important like
a first impression is
uh best of luck seem really chill to
hang out with thank you yeah I try to
try to keep it real best I can
apparently uh I don't know if I should
comment on that too much but
I think a lot of people find me
intimidating to hang out with
um
just I don't know I don't know why
I think it's because I'm a bit of a
a bit of a hard head like I know what I
want to do and it's it's kind of I'm
doing it
so I'm not very uh
open to new experiences I guess at times
like most people I hang out with they'll
be like hey let's go out to the bar go
dancing like no thanks I'm just gonna
chill
and be like you're boring I'm like yep
it's not boring to me
see you later
that's what usually happens
so it's just kind of hard to find other
people with the same mindset as me I
guess
but thank you I'd probably I'd probably
have a lot of fun hanging out with you a
lot of you guys because I think people
that now that uh gravitate towards my
channel probably you know more like me
you meet people in the real world it's a
different most of them aren't coders
most of them don't think logically like
that you know
have you ever tried different
domain I used to waste almost all my
time on CG papers
pet engines like Wicked but I find
myself behind people work on tools
like reality cap and image generators
uh uh that's interesting
trying to think how to answer that
hmm
I definitely tried different domains I
went into web development for about a
year
I went into Android programming with
Java for about two years
and ultimately I just noped out of those
and went back to C plus plus
um
I've def I've worked quite a bit with
unreal quite a bit with unity
but I guess by quite a bit it's not
actually quite a bit like I learned
enough to get some of the basics down
all right see you krill
cabrill
thanks for the questions
so I don't know that's a hard question
to answer but I think when you when you
have a specific project of your own that
you're working on
you end up learning
that stuff pretty well so
when you're just kind of messing around
with other people's stuff
I feel like you don't learn as much of
the not in not as much of the deep
knowledge at least you might learn I
don't know
I don't know how to answer that exactly
or if that's entirely true but for me at
least I feel like when I'm working on my
own things
like if I need to make my own image
generator I'm going to learn a lot more
than just using somebody's library that
generates images
but it's often a good idea to get
started with a pre-built tool and then
if you can dig into the code later
that's cool
Yak gives you source code from BNF
grammar okay gotcha
I forget what BNF means
what
no I know I learned about this in school
and I just totally forget
medicine tax notation context-free
grammar so yeah okay I had some I I'd
forget exactly all that but it looks
familiar
oh it's just like where you have like
tokens of different things and you put
them together
what do you do for work
many various things mainly coding and
teaching
um
and uh some gaming stuff too
I don't have a I guess my main job is
still working on the game engine for now
you should apply at Paradox Bethesda
rock star yeah I don't think I could I
mean I could but
I don't think they would hire me
I mean I I don't know I shouldn't say
that
just not that interested I guess right
now really is what it comes down to
you should go back to school get in the
r d realm work for Sandy National Labs
and whatnot
not sure
the idea of working for a big already
established company is you know it looks
very nice on the resume
but if I really ask myself if it would
like
I I don't know that it would actually
uh feel that great to me
pass on a resume if you need that's okay
I I haven't updated my resume in years
and it's I think it's kind of ugly right
now I need to refactor it before I pass
it anywhere
and I'm
I don't really want to move I like I
said I live in a small rural town and I
kind of like it it's like just a really
nice little college town
and I just don't really want to move
most companies like oh you got to move
across halfway across the world but you
can work at this big company and like
yeah I don't really want to
especially since my my kid is going
through school right now and I'd have to
uproot them and take them to a different
school and
it would be
a big change which I'd be willing to do
to some extent
but with these companies there's no
guarantee like what if I uproot myself
and move there and then I get fired in a
week I mean you really have no control
of whether a company keeps you or not no
matter how good you do
as far as you know there could be one
guy that's
like even if you this is the thing with
these jobs it's like very annoying at
least to me
is if you do really well like if you
like go above and beyond and you're like
the best employee ever
that's actually a case that can get you
fired it's like there's no winning in
these corporate jobs you have to get
lucky
at least that's my take on it because
like there might be like one upper guy
that sees you as someone that's going to
take his position and you have no
control over this you're just trying to
do the right thing and trying to be good
and useful but there's this one guy
that's like has control over your
position
and uh they can say oh he's too good
he's making me look bad because he's so
good uh fire him and he's like I worked
so hard to get here did so well and I
got fired for it are you kidding me like
it's a bizarre world
so that's why I'm kind of scared to even
ever commit to like any of these big
jobs
like uh for real for real like oh this
is my life now so I'd rather you know I
kind of have because of that whole
thing I basically would have to
um yeah I either have to be fully remote
or I'd have to be in charge just
I wouldn't be able to take being an
employee it's
for long I actually did it for a while I
was in an r d company working on a math
library for a while and
it was good things were good
it's a great job made some good friends
I don't think I had any risk of getting
fired there I was making good money but
it was too far away ultimately like I
was commuting a lot until it became
permanent and the commute was I was
basically never home
and like my home life just started
falling apart it was miserable the job
was great but like it just destroyed my
family life my kid was getting in
trouble
and uh I don't know just had all these
problems at home happening and I was
like I can't do anything about it
because I'm too busy with work and I'm
like I gotta make a choice
and I chose my family
that was that was tough one of the
toughest times of my life
uh
any game recommendations
uh what do you mean like to play or to
work on
send you an email a couple weeks ago
about a job that's fully remote
except the one time of year you get
flown out
I might have missed that
I'm not sure
not sure if I see saw that email
uh
it's really hard to tell what emails are
real and what or not
um in my email there's like so many spam
ones it's crazy
so it's just really difficult to tell
it's legit not
so I might have thought it was a
non-legit email not sure
but yeah anything that's fully remote I
would at least be open to considering
someone's pinging me on something
cool
the best place to reach me and for me to
know it's legit is basically through one
of the paid support methods because I
know someone joins one of those they're
actually serious
like uh like the patreon or something
like that
there's a lot of stuff that just like
comes in and out of the blue and I
really have no idea what to think of it
sometimes and I can't spend too much
time on
on every little thing that comes in it's
usually just a quick scan it's like
you know what's my initial feeling or so
I guess a lot of them I don't even see
probably
okay I got to the end of the chat I
caught up
all right I'll hang around for a couple
more minutes because this drink is not
empty but uh
sounds like I've answered most of your
guys's questions I really appreciate you
guys coming to hang out
I'll send you one to the one you have a
list on YouTube yeah sure
what name should I be looking for
that helps if I know what name I'm
looking for
foreign
it also didn't help that the fact that
one of the first sponsors I ever tried
to take turned out to be a scam so that
was just like okay
after that I was like I see we don't
take these emails seriously got it
Dre okay
foreign
I will look out for your email
all right
all right any last things fellas
let me show you guys hope you do well
music have you been listening to lately
mostly
just kind of chill wave stuff retro wave
that kind of stuff
um it depends on my mood though I listed
a little bit of everything when I was
young it was a lot of hard rock a lot of
thrashy stuff
I guess that was also when I was playing
music I don't really play much anymore
but uh
yeah recently it's mostly
when coding is classical from gaming I
like to have some upbeat stuff a little
uh retro wave or heavy industrial type
stuff I try to avoid lyrics for the most
part lyrics really
don't I don't know I Like Lyrics
sometimes but not when I'm focusing on
something
what do you think about Chad GPT
it's good I like it it's definitely not
a
end-all be-all it's like a better Google
to me that's what I feel like chat GPT
is it's like Google 2.0 I use it today
actually help me figure out some stuff
but you know the problem I was talking
about earlier with physics player
controller it did not help me figure out
that it was just leading me through the
weeds through all kinds of nonsense on
that
I had to figure that one out on my own
but uh generally it's pretty good I like
it
I use it over Google by default
listen to stealth by stagers are okay
I'll have to check them out
uh have you ever thought about updating
your cmake tutorial yeah
yeah I started doing it I redid episode
two
I might redo some other ones at some
point
but
I guess I'm kind of doing it on a
case-by-case basis
there's definitely I'm definitely way
more advanced with with CMAC I have a
way better understanding of cmake now
than I did back when I made those
so I could definitely do a better job
but I don't know did I do I'm trying to
find the ones where
I could definitely improve them like if
I just remake it and it's like barely
better it's not quite worth it I don't
think but if I can remake it it's way
better then it's worth it so I feel like
I feel like I could do that with episode
two so I just completely redid it and
I think it's better people seem to seem
to like it seems to be better in
teaching
C make and how it ties in with C plus
plus
because we yeah I was I was really like
I said I was winging out I was fumbling
through that
that sometimes as you could tell I typo
things and had to edit it in to make it
make it look like it was a clever lesson
and stuff like that you know that was
not on purpose
I was just
I just I was like oh God I really don't
want to re-record this let me just make
some edits and try to make it passable
so that's the way it is sometimes
because
it's like I have a limited
limited time to do the video I'm working
on
and uh if I totally botch a recording
I either have to find a way to salvage
it or re-record and uh
yeah there's times I've
I can't even tell you guys how many
botched videos I have that just never
came out it's probably in the hundreds
there's so many that I've like I started
going and then when I'm like halfway
through I'm like oh my goodness this is
so convoluted and confusing there's no
way I can release this
so I don't
there's a bunch of those
and who knows maybe maybe some of them
were better than I thought I don't
really know but
I try to only put out the better ones
it's just the way it goes especially
when you do them like this I don't
really script stuff I've started to
script videos a little bit more that's
actually a really good idea but
in the past I did not it was always wing
it and uh I guess that's just my style
always been kind of a wing it person
all right fellas
all right stealth and moth I'll check
those out I'm gonna put them in a
notepad right now so I don't forget
your email appreciate you guys
appreciate any and all support
gotta do some cool stuff for this new
year good luck with all your projects
and coding hope you found this useful
glad I could finally sit down and do the
the 10K live stream
better late than never better late than
never
all right fellas
take it easy have a good evening or
morning
see you around